hello this is white on the show good
tech help you kick tobacco hold on tight
I go flying without wings and a return
to the halfpipe but is it half base this
week we're at Wired 2015 it's a tech
event that showcases innovators and
creations that could change the world
we're here to have a go on one
particular contraption which works
muscles in a way you might not have seen
before which is why I'm in my gym kit
you see we wanted this week's episode to
be all about getting healthier it is
stocked oba after all the month which
emphasizes quitting smoking which is why
chris has been taking a look at the tech
that can help you kick the habit
this is a cigarette case that claims
it'll help you give up smoking sensors
monitor your usage and feed the info to
a smartphone app the data is then used
to create a quitting plan tailored to
your behavior by collecting data on each
individual's habits we can determine
what their unique triggers are versus
you know slapping a nicotine patch on
your shoulder or giving you some
nicotine gum to chew it really takes
your information and what makes you
unique as a smoker and what makes you
addicted and then it tackles all of
those different facets other products
aimed at helping people kick the habit
include a connected lighter it has a
built-in display that lets you know how
often you're using it and it can be
linked to an app to help you set goals
or how about a smart cigarette holder to
see works out how much nicotine and tar
you're consuming every time you inhale
for the competitive types this app turns
quitting into a game users can unlock
achievements and level up as they
progress whereas apps like this one let
smokers keep track of how much they're
spending on cigarettes kristen is a
former smoker she says technology gave
her that extra bit of motivation when it
came to staying smoke-free the app that
i've been using has helped me deal with
cravings so i'll login creaming that i
have and it'll give me tips on how to
surpass it and it's also giving me like
positive reinforcement with you know
completing missions and getting badges
and so it's like gave a firing factor
that is that has also helped me to keep
me on the right
smart devices and apps could help people
give up smoking but some experts are
concerned they could have negative
effects too first of all it may delay
you from stopping smoking because you
learned into Fort sense of acuity that
you're doing something positive for your
health when you're not the second is
that really when you cut down on secure
consumption is right quite a lot of
these devices such as you do you
actually smoke cigarettes harder so
you're certainly not reducing your
intake of toxins these products aren't
marketed as a substitute for willpower
but with many of them being funded by
crowdsourcing campaigns it's clear that
there's a demand for them Chris Cregan
Sky News you're watching swype still to
come I go cruising over mountains but
first here's a roundup of some of this
week's other tech news a muscle
stimulating sports web project which
launched on IndieGoGo this week raised
more than fifty percent of its target in
its first hour on the crowdfunding site
antelopes fabric uses technology that
forces muscle contractions with
electrical impulses the creator's say
the clothing helps you perform better
and get stronger one of the developers
behind a new mobile game about migration
has told us he hopes it'll get players
thinking and talking about the issue
cloud chasers sees you guide a father
and daughter on their journey to a
better life art is a part of society a
very important art artist thing in
society they get started thinking about
things and I think games need to do the
same Owings been showing off what's said
to be the lightest metal ever the micro
lattice is actually ninety-nine point
nine nine percent air and apparently
light enough to balance on top of a
dandelion but the company says its
unique structure means it's also strong
making it a potential metal for lighter
and more fuel-efficient airplanes
welcome our words stick around for our
games review some childhood favorites
make a comeback
now you know that contraption I
mentioned earlier this is it it's called
Icarus it's an exercise machine with
virtual reality and with me is one of
the co-inventors you harness I could see
it now we're about to go flying over
mountains it's what we're about to do to
increase my speed very good this is
amazing this is beautiful I can feel it
working my body though I can feel that I
have to keep my cool locked in I can
feel the muscles in my legs I mean here
did you aim this at who is this fool
well we wanted to make gaming more
active we wanted to make workouts just
less boring for people so we see this in
gems at the first step but later on also
in people's private households of course
it's so it's a prototype at the moment
it is still the prototype but we're
aiming for serial production now and
we'll start within this year actually I
feel like this might be a little bit big
to put in my living room for example
well it's not that big compared to other
gym equipment but of course also the
version four people households will be a
bit smaller than this one here have you
got any advice on how I'm flying well
yeah you could be a bit less hectic just
do tiny me if it's a tactic it's all
about balance smooth flying just relax
yourself and enjoy the views now what
kind of workout would you recommend what
people need to use this every day or
three times a week and how long for
ideally every day it really works your
core muscles which are quite hard to
train so your abs your lower back
muscles shoulders so every day 20 minute
worker would be great for people okay
you know I'm gonna pause right there I
was trying to build a little bit queasy
thank you for showing me that while I
get my balance back Luke has been
working on his this week here he is in
our games review about a decade ago the
Tony Hawk's Pro Skater series was
incredible every kid my age used to play
them and they had a killer soundtrack
the lights blink 182 amazing bands that
you know kind of really defined a
generation so when activision announced
they were making a new game they were
making Tony Hawk's Pro Skater 5 everyone
was very very excited
unfortunately the game itself has failed
to deliver it might be showing my age
but unfortunately the soundtrack just
don't have a clue who any of them are
but also in terms of gameplay it doesn't
quite capture the essence of what the
original game was about it's very very
buggy and glitchy and Activision have
said that they will be patching it in
the future to make it playable because
at the moment it really really isn't but
for the time being definitely hold off
and put your money elsewhere uncharted
the Nathan Drake collection is basically
a bundle of the first three games in the
series you've got uncharted one
uncharted two and uncharted 3 but
they're remastered and features have
been improved for release on ps4 so this
is from Naughty Dog who the guys who
brought us the last of us which is a
fantastic game and it's basically where
a lot of the great ideas the last of us
came from in terms of gameplay it's
being rereleased for a lot of people who
switched from Xbox to PlayStation
consoles ahead of the release of
uncharted 4 which wraps everything up
next year it is a fantastic game and
they were great the first time around
they look even better now so even if you
have played them before I would highly
recommend giving them another go
transformers devastation gives you the
opportunity to go into one of the
cartoons of your childhood by playing as
one of five Autobots including the likes
of Optimus Prime and Bumblebee so it's
based on the generation 1 transform as
you know the nostalgic ones that
originally went out there before they
completely got touched up by Michael Bay
and all of this it's a really really
good game developed by a company called
platinum who have a very very good
history of hack and slash games like
Bayonetta and some other big ones have
got a game called scalebound coming out
next year on xbox one it's a very good
game held back by some issues in terms
of camera controls but the action combat
is fast paced it's furious and it's
incredibly enjoyable and it's a gorgeous
thing to look at so if your Transformers
fan or just looking for some mindless
violence by all means
is the one for you when people think of
Japanese RPGs more often than not people
think of final fantasy but in actual
fact there's another series that in
Japan is just as big and it's called the
tales of series so this is actually the
fifteenth entry in the series and tales
of zestiria is the first one that's
going to be on PlayStation 4 they're
really making a big push with this one
to make it appealed Western audiences so
they've given it a big open world the
combat has been retuned so it's not
turn-based it's very very action-packed
and you know you're doing it in real
time the characters are really engaging
and very appealing and the storyline and
thematically deals with some darker and
more serious terms and stuff but the
other games deal with it's not going to
be to everyone's taste by no question
but I really do think that if you
haven't given a JRPG ago in a long while
or you're just looking for something a
little bit different this is possibly
something you'll want to check out
that's it take a look at sky knees on
mobile and iPad for some more techniques
see you next week bye bye
you